[Applause]
thanks ville it's an honor to be here at
e3 and represent three years of
engineering the team has done to bring
you Xbox 1x from the beginning our focus
on game creators and you the gamer gave
us three big goals we needed to hit
power compatibility and craftsmanship
let's talk power which starts with the
specs six teraflop GPU clocked at one
point one seven two gigahertz twelve
gigabytes of gddr5 memory and 326
gigabytes per second of memory bandwidth
[Applause]
these are impressive numbers that are
more powerful than any other console on
every dimension because that's what it
takes to give game creators the power
they need so you can experience true 4k
resolution 4k textures and 4k assets in
your living room and when we say true 4k
we mean 8 million pixels high dynamic
range wide color gamut premium sound
like dolby atmos and 4k UHD blu-ray
playback
next compatibility we knew compatibility
was critically important for Xbox one X
and your reaction to 360 backward
compatibility is energize the team even
more so right from the start all of your
Xbox one accessories and games will work
with Xbox one X but for the team in me
that wasn't good enough we wanted more
the game library you have today will
look and play even better on Xbox one X
with enhanced visual fidelity
anisotropic filtering and faster load
times even if you haven't made the jump
to a 4k TV yet we designed this product
for you as well since Xbox one X enables
a technique called super sampling the
new 4k games you see on stage today will
look better on your 1080p TV than
anything you've seen before and finally
craftsmanship we meticulously paid
attention to every detail of design as
we crafted our most technically advanced
console ever it starts with the Scorpio
engine we use 16 nanometer technology to
build a 360 square millimeter chip with
seven billion transistors and a 384 bit
wide memory bus this is the fastest most
advanced processor to ever power a
console our premium design means that
every millimeter and every component
within the console has been architected
for maximum power and efficiency our
aspirations were so high an industry
standard approach just wasn't good
enough
the Scorpio engine is so intense that
for the first time ever on a console
we're using a liquid cooled vapor
chamber normally reserved for servers
and high-end PC
[Applause]
an engineer on the Xbox hardware team
invented a new power management system
so innovative we named it after him the
Hovis method uniquely optimizes every
single Xbox one X at the system and
component level to deliver consistent
performance efficiently and elegantly
now it's easy to think all this
technology and capability will mean a
bigger console but again we wanted more
not only have we built the most powerful
console ever Xbox one X is the smallest
Xbox ever
this is the system you asked us to build
and it has been a great honor to design
and build it for you
I couldn't be more proud of our team and
I hope you love it as much as we do now
let's see what this monster can do
[Applause]